soon you'll be able to earn virtual
currency and virtual reality if you take
the number of hours that you spend
looking at a screen a good chunk of that
maybe all of that gets replaced with a
VR helmet which means that for a good
chunk of people in the world the
majority of their waking hours are gonna
be spent in the matrix the Silicon
Valley entrepreneur apology's Srinivasan
is a modern-day polymath who venture
capitalists Marc Andreessen has called
the person with the highest output per
minute of new ideas of anybody I've ever
met in my life
a PhD in electrical engineering a
co-founder of a genetic testing firm and
a Stanford computer science lecturer
Srinivasan was also on Donald Trump's
shortlist to head up the Food and Drug
Administration today he spends most of
his time as CEO of the cryptocurrency
startup earn calm serene of Austin
believes in the power of technology to
provide a way for individuals to migrate
away from ossified institutions or
destructive policies borrowing from the
classic book by Alberto Hirshman he
refers to this path as exit while we
talk a lot about voice in the context of
the US and talk about democracy that's
very important but you know we're not
just a nation of immigrants we're a
nation of immigrants were shaped by both
voice and exit voice gains much more
attention when people are leaving in
droves one of the things I think a lot
about is if you've got an existing
system and it's ossified there's kind of
at least two responses here there's more
than two but at least two one is you
know voice which in its extremis is
revolution revolution is extreme voice
where you know it's saying oh I'm so
dizzy is you know like a like a much
more limited version of that but still
also effective in many cases you know
you can actually vote to go and change
things alternatively if you believe that
you know it's going to be too hard to
change things that way but you're also
cognizant of the fact that certain
people like it that way there's an
alternative you can proceed which is X
right you say okay I'm not going to
change the system I recognized why you
guys have it the way it is but doesn't
suit my preferences so I'm going to
leave and start something new all
progress is really the process of you
exit you build something up and then it
gets ossified and the next generation
exits again for example a startup starts
and what happens is the libertarian
founder ends up rebuilding the state
that is to say you start as like an
individual and often people do that
because they want to
total autonomy and control and then what
they find is as they get to a certain
scale well they sort of need to have
some policies you need to have something
in place so that you don't have like 500
autonomous people just moving in their
own direction we have 500 people working
as a team what startup gets big enough
then you got to bring in an HR exactly
you got a search thing now you really
you got to wear shoes in the office you
got to do this oh let's have stuff
exactly and so as you transition from
like burn rate to bust number bus number
is how many people can get hit by a bus
for this thing to continue enduring on
once your bus number has to be bigger
than one for every position you start to
actually have to view people as
replaceable because if they're not
replaceable you haven't done your job
right as kind of you know the founder
and that's a critical transition that
happens in companies where they
transition from a collection of
individuals to a multicellular organism
now what happens then is if that goes
too far
you get initiative being kind of
constrained you get bureaucracy you get
all these kinds of things that
potentially in the long term are to the
detriment of that multicellular organism
and they cause people to leave and
that's exit and then you start a new
thing srinivasan ceases current venture
earned calm as a tool that ultimately
could provide workers exit the company
allows individuals to get paid for
accomplishing small tasks like
completing surveys and answering emails
what if we could kind of exit the
current system of how folks try to
employ others and get jobs and so on and
actually have like a completely
frictionless digital workforce right
where you could hire anyone from
anywhere and if they had the merit they
could do the job now there's all kinds
of national boundary issues compliance
issues regulatory issues etc but as an
ideal um what if you start with
something which pays you to reply to
emails but then in five or ten years you
open up earn calm anywhere and you've
just got a feat of tasks and that's your
job sort of actually like Marx talked
about even you know in the comics
manifesto he talked about hey you know
wouldn't it be awesome if you could be a
hunter in the morning and a tailor at
night and switch through all these
different professions um you know what
if you could actually do that in such a
way that didn't involve killing people
right like the gumming isn't dead right
what if you could just actually you know
flip through these tasks look at all the
ones you're qualified for do this this
and this guess what you made a hundred
dollars for that day and it's a it's an
interesting twist on exit because you
know you know the Pilgrims left or the
Puritans left England moved to America
to try something right here you can
actually you can stay at night
you can place you could you I mean we're
living in multiple communities and
multiple orders at any given point in
time that's exactly right and I think
that's um what technology is doing is
it's reducing the barrier to exit and
there's two dimensions on which that is
true the first is a dimension that you
just remark about which let's call that
the cloud dimension right because the
cloud you can earn from anywhere you can
collaborate from anywhere and soon
you'll be able to join like a VR world
and are in virtual currency and virtual
reality right and if you finally realize
that you hate you hate your co-workers
in the cloud just as much as you do in
the office maybe yeah exactly but if so
three that's utopian right so you can
hit the back button and just warp into
another virtual reality right so um I
think that particular combination by the
way VR with virtual currency is going to
be a huge huge thing on we haven't yet
hit you know the the next dog leg up in
VR there's something missing there's
probably gonna be an iPhone of VR kind
of moment something something is not yet
being you know out there in the market
but when that thing actually hits um
you're gonna see something very
interesting which is if you take the
number of hours that you spend looking
at a screen right for many people many
of the folks you know who are
information workers that's the majority
of waking hours of your day especially
if you add up the you know I'm not
looking at your phone and your tablet
and what-have-you right so a good chunk
of that maybe all of that gets replaced
with a VR helmet which means that for a
good chunk of people in the world the
majority of their waking hours are gonna
be spent in the matrix you're gonna be
earning in the matrix and you're gonna
be earning with coworkers who are from
Brazil and Japan and all this other
stuff and so machine translation becomes
extremely important right real-time
machine translation digital currency
becomes extremely important because you
need to be able to transact across
borders and where people are being
organized as by their interest not
necessarily by their geography right so
it's called at the cloud axis where you
can kind of just put on your VR headset
jack in and you know you'll be part of
whatever kind of group around the world
you want on the two senses that are
missing are taste and smell but you'll
be able to get sight and sound and then
with haptics and kind of omnidirectional
treadmills you can get touch so haptics
people probably know about you know your
hands will drive rate and so on
omnidirectional treadmills are kind of
what they sound like where you don't
just walk in one direction but you can
walk in 360 degrees being developed for
games now to give a much more immersive
experience
each of those three you can do most
things other than you know touch and
taste and smell the second major axis is
mobile mobile is making us more mobile
your geography becomes less important
but that what I mean is you know there's
a logic that is held really since the
Treaty of Westphalia which is that
implicitly your neighbors share your
values and your physical neighbors and
you roughly agree on what the law is for
that jurisdiction all right
increasing what's happening is you know
you live in an apartment complex and you
wouldn't even recognize your neighbors
but you have long conversations with
somebody a thousand miles away right you
know there's a one-liner which says you
know snapchat is on the straight line
with the dissolution of the nation-state
because you're sharing intimate moments
with people who are hundreds or
thousands of miles away and you don't
know your next-door neighbor
Serena Boston says Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies are another key
technology in creating a borderless
world because they make it possible to
transfer value anywhere without relying
on a trusted intermediary well then calm
if you're sending a message to a
thousand people in a hundred different
countries and you want to pay them about
ten dollars to reply to an email or fill
out a survey that be the kind of thing
where wire transfer fees would kill you
if you're using Swift to do that and
it'd just be a huge hassle to try to
automate all those wires plus would be
hard to get people on the other side to
set up bank account integration for just
relatively small amounts of payment so
for all of those reasons together it
becomes something we're paying people
small amounts of money across borders
quickly and settling it is the kind of
thing that cryptocurrency is very good
for and the block she's very good for
that was not possible in previous world
what I mean by Silicon Valley's ultimate
exit
it basically means build an opt-in
society run by technology drones warfare
is going to become software laws gonna
become code management via robotics is
going to become automation and property
rights are gonna become a network effect
in that 2013 talk you you discussed how
Silicon Valley which is a physical place
yep
but it's separating from other great
cities Boston as like the ultimate
education city New York as the ultimate
commercial DC as the ultimate legal or
giver of laws LA and entertainment
Silicon Valley was separating from that
in various ways but is there something
about space so you know Silicon Valley
in many ways is the outgrowth of you
know of Stanford and Berkeley and a
couple of other universities plus
one or two companies going back to the
50s whether it's Fairchild Semiconductor
or whatever I mean that you know where
you you can kind of create a family tree
would that kind of stuff happened if
these people were not meeting in close
proximity and can you can you replace
that in virtual space yeah so that's a
very important question and I think
though there's a bunch of factors that
are going to lead to decentralization of
Technology out of Silicon Valley there's
the cost of real estate you know just
the the fact that immigration to the US
is becoming more challenging for in many
different ways the home countries are
doing better now right like you know
India's really not that bad do you want
to live anymore
and every year of remote work technology
becomes better and better right you get
slack you get you know like better
mobile hangouts and video and all those
things kind of keep improving in
companies that are just starting out
they have something very interesting
which is they have the ability to go and
negotiate with cities and negotiate with
countries so for example um let's say
you're you know a country that's got a
sovereign fund you want to track
technology to your to your locale you
say guess what we're not gonna regulate
cryptocurrency for the next you know ten
years black sheeting regulation
moratorium come on in the water's warm
and in will also take a five percent
stake in your company through our
sovereign funds right so I think you're
gonna see a lot more stuff like that
does that bother you as a form of crony
capitalism that might really screw up
markets so no it doesn't and and and the
reason is because so first disclosure
like it's something where it's gonna be
done in a very aboveboard way these are
reputable sovereign phones and whatnot
um second there's competition because
you know if Dubai wants get in the
bidding if Israel wants get in the
bidding of Estonia does I'm sure that
company would be interested and the
thing um third is there should if
everything goes well be a significant
benefit to the locale you know because
guess what they've they've got the next
Detroit or the next Wall Street or
whatever there because they adopted
self-driving cars or they dropped in
cryptocurrency and blockchain earlier so
you know whereas crony capitalism is
usually like more like a bribe or a
payoff that's done non transparently
that's um without a competitive process
and that doesn't actually benefit the
population so do you think the locale or
and I guess part of it depends on the
final price tag but we have seen you
know just
grotesque outpouring of graft of honest
crap
bubbling graph from cities saying you
know Amazon put your headquarters here
and we'll give you five billion dollars
right we'll stop we won't charge you any
taxes we'll build the infrastructure
will do this Dallas says they're getting
a build a high-speed rail stop you know
at the Amazon HQ it comes to Dallas
where the train would go from there who
knows right I mean is is there any way
that that's actually good for capitalism
or good for markets well so first is
it's a refreshing change from the
opposite which is um if if you have a
jurisdiction that takes a large entity
like Amazon for granted they can just
pile on the taxes pile on the
regulations and eventually they you know
whether they kill the Golden Goose or
they just stop it from building of that
region that's one thing right so this is
a refreshing change in the other
direction frankly with that said there's
principal-agent issues right where you
know for example that HS high-speed rail
thing or what have you
maybe it's something where the mayor or
the governor is effectively spending
money out of their own not out of their
own pocket but out of their constituents
pockets for something that's you know
like like not actually that beneficial I
think what happens is over time you get
a market process that lands you
somewhere in the middle you know if they
don't act in your interest well US isn't
also the ability to move because taxes
got too high in your reach you used to
particularly on your Twitter account
which is kind of on missing lighter side
but you used to cite the 1997 book the
sovereign individual Sherrod how do what
is that book and how does that inform
your worldview so awesome book and it's
also Peter keels one of his favorites
he's talked about that although other
folks liked it a lot in Silicon Valley
the thing about that book is it's kind
of like is it's like the book of
prophecies and what I mean by that is it
was written in 1999 and you open and you
read through it and many of the
sentences seem like they were ripped
from last week's headlines right and and
some of them have yet to happen and so
what's remarkable about this is that
typically when you take a nonfiction
book like say you know like a Malcolm
Gladwell look or something like that you
can often summarize 400 pages in the
sentence whereas the sovereign
individual is the opposite where I could
take a sentence in it I could expand
that into its own book and so in a
nutshell what the thesis is is that
there's different ages of
three and you know during these
different ages the relationship between
property and violence has changed now
we're transitioning into a new era where
you know the network and the nature of
property on respect to digital currency
and other kinds of things relate to the
blockchain is something where no amount
of violence can solve a math problem and
so what that means is if you just know
somebody's wish you have told that to my
nun math teacher sure they could apply
to you that might not solve many
problems right but the thing about that
is you might see one hundred million
dollars in the Bitcoin blockchain on but
first you need to identify that person
who has that which is non-trivial in its
own right and then second you would have
to figure out how to get that private
key from that person which again is not
that easy to do it's not like you know
the wire transfer system where you can
just hit a button and just you know
garnish the wages or debit the account
that's a very new thing what that does
that shifts the logic of violence where
it used to be that if you had you know
the biggest military you could always
take the most money but that's not going
to necessarily be the case as things
move forward and so the sovereign
individual is about is tracing that
thesis through um in much more detailed
and we're currently talking about and
saying okay what happens when you can't
just see somebody's money right now
there's good things that happen which is
that well you know everything becomes
voluntary and you know you if you're a
wealth creator you can keep the wealth
that you create there's bad things that
happen which is that if robberies happen
if criminals happen it's harder to
follow the money cut off their flow of
funds and so one of the things that you
know the guy predicts is you're both
going to have more upside and more
downside right you're gonna have like
these incredible cities and
organizations that push the frontiers
you're gonna have lots more petty crime
but one thing you're probably also going
to have a lot less of our massive wars
there might be like one big transitional
war as you kind of go into the new era
but after that point because you can't
just see his funds it becomes harder for
governments just cease funds for their
military to start wars so on net I think
it's actually a very positive thesis for
kind of humanity um but there's going to
be some rocky transitional moments
between now and then Srinivasan actually
began his career as an entrepreneur with
the healthcare startup while he was
teaching at Stanford a decade ago he and
his older brother
Ramji founded the genetic testing firm
council which aims to improve the way
genetic diseases are identified and
treated what are the most popular
services that council offers to people
they've got several different jack
testing services but the the first and
kind of the flagship product is a test
for every major Mendelian genetic
disease and one way of thinking about
this is part of council it was common
for doctors to go and sort of
imprecisely bucket people by ethnicity
okay so this couple is African American
this couple is Jewish American this
couple is Southeast Asian and so on and
then they would say okay this group is
at risk for sickle-cell anemia and this
group is at risk for tay-sachs and this
group for beta thalassemia and whatnot
right but for many different reasons
first is that ethnic bucketing is
imprecise right for example Obama is at
risk for both sickle-cell anemia and
cystic fibrosis because in at least two
ethnic groups and second it's it's
actually it's not just imprecise it will
mean that you don't catch every risk
allele right and you know there's
African American subscribers genes and
vice versa and third is it's also
something which is error-prone because
you sometimes don't test somebody for
something that they should have been
tested for so instead what we were able
to do is take all of these Mendelian
genetic diseases and test for them in
one assay which is actually cheaper than
the blood based assays that used to
happen with with this new kind of
genomic test
and before you'd have to basically do
these individual tests for each one and
now you can just one unified what do
people do if they both realize they're
you know the husband and wife or
whatever our case X carriers then they
choose not to have kids or do they do
IVF and do selective embryos and things
like that yes so they've got several
different options so the earlier you
know the more options you have right so
you know Doria sherene for example
actually does this kind of testing even
before marriage so that a couple can
choose whether to get married or not
right that's that's a couple that's an
organization to this jewishnet testing
hen matchmaking together if you know
after marriage but before conception
then yes you can do in vitro
fertilization plus a procedure called
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis where
you take a plate of embryos so I've been
fertilized you diagnosed them prior to
implanting into the mo
and you find the one that does not have
the genetic disease as gene editing
technologies advanced and cost plummet
some bioethicists have expressed concern
that in the future parents will abort
children with genetic diseases or
creates occult designer babies whose
genes are altered to improve their
intelligence or physical appearance the
state of Ohio just banned recently at
the end of 2017 and I I don't know
exactly how they're going to enforce
this or whatever but they banned
abortion based on amniocentesis or a
sonogram that showed that a fetus has
Down syndrome how do you feel about that
kind of intervention well so first is
the IVF PGD thing that I talked about is
not abortion right and so the advantage
of that is it's something that you know
both increases reproductive choice so
it's something that the left get behind
and it reduces a number of
determinations because you know prior to
you know when the child has a thing so
that's maybe the right can get behind
so in general we try to look for those
kind of women drugs with something like
the Ohio matter it's very hard to get
inside a woman's head and try to
restrict her autonomy on something like
that certainly I'm not in favor of a law
like that but you know I think that it's
also something's very difficult to
enforce because you could probably just
drive across you know the boys so again
to bring it back to exit you know this
is the type of thing where the law a a
state literally you know big or small
tries to maintain a certain code you
know law and people can exit that system
relatively easily great yeah that's
right and I think and I guess what your
technology would do it counsel is that
it allows it helps you're not always and
not perfectly but it helps you really
minimize the chances you're going to be
in a situation where something like that
would be it that's right because
basically by knowing prior to the
pregnancy that's when you have both more
reproductive choice and you have fewer
terminations so you don't actually have
to have that trade-off you know like if
you know prior to it right and that's
generally a Silicon Valley thing is the
more information you can get earlier the
more educated an informed decision you
can make you talked with President Trump
about being the head of the FDA base
based on your experience with counsel
what was that like what was he like
and what would you have done if you had
actually become the head of the FDA I
think that the current head the FDA is
actually doing some good things like I
like what
Scott has been doing on the legalization
of dtc genomics and he has reduced the
barriers to entry for medical apps and
and stuff like that I think that there
are areas like CRISPR for example where
the United States is potentially in
danger of falling behind and then CRISPR
is relatively easy gene editing yeah
that's right yeah so very fundamental
technology which is just being pursued
aggressively for example in China
there's a Wall Street Journal article on
this the other day but it's common
knowledge to the people who are in the
field and so there's areas where you
know it just may be something where you
know computer innovation happened in the
United States but many kinds of biotech
innovation may just have to be done
outside the United States and is that
because I did will try to say it as
politely as possible and I'm not sure
that it will be but it's just that in
certain countries either the government
is in charge and that can kind of force
a level of experimentation we're
comfortable with or they don't have the
same kind of moral hangups
you know that we might have in the
United States I think it's I think it's
a little different than that it's not I
mean cuz this is not the 1970s China
where it's like you know forced abortion
right and so on
um this is much more of a free market
you know I'm not saying I'm chasing or
even of South Korea has clearly been
doing a lot of stuff that would not
would not even be tried in the United
States right right right so so I think
the way a different way of thinking
about it is that these are still you
know civilizations countries that feel
like they're on the rise and you know
when America was kind of confident like
that there are plenty of folks who are
volunteer test pilots you know planes
didn't just start to fly themselves or
guys who took you know very substantial
risks as being the first people to pilot
an experimental aircraft and a bunch of
people died if you go to the history of
automobiles or aviation or railroads
a lot of people died if you look at the
history of chemistry there was you know
the the CRC Handbook of chemistry and
physics prior to you know kind of the
modern era has lots of tastes and smells
for compounds because people used to
just taste and smell new compounds right
and I'm sure there was some guy who you
know sniff some cyanide and last thing
he wrote down was almonds and either
laps and he
took one for the team basically and kind
of advanced science right and so you
know the way that I sort of think about
it is if euthanasia is legal right if
you can choose to end one's own life if
it's legal to go in bungee jumping
skydiving if it's legal to go and fight
in a war and potentially die for a
futile reason well then it should be
legal to take an in-form risk for a
treatment that could help you right I
mean essentially your body your choice
right I would try to have the United
States be competitive for the rest of
the world and one way that you could do
that is actually try to keep most or
really all of the existing FDA intact
but look to what the FAA and you know
the some other regulatory agencies are
doing so for example the FAA has these
drones owns that have been opened in
various areas which are meant to in low
you know lightly populated areas allow
the flying of drones with less
regulation right um there's also these
so-called FinTech regulatory sand boxes
where you can have startup companies
with less regulatory overhead than they
would have you know if they had to
comply with the full panoply of laws and
you've got almost like charter schools
where you where you give you give like a
space for innovation and experiment
loaded term so but but I'd say I call it
a special innovation zone by analogy to
a special economic zone relatively few
people know how big a deal special
economic zones are but outside the
United States there were like the
primary engine of growth for China and
for other countries and if we did
something like that here where where we
already got a precedent for it with the
drone zones and the self-driving car
zones and so on we might be able to have
a zone let's say you know the Mayo
Clinic was overseeing it where it was
moving doctor willing patient who are
your intellectual and business heroes
and how do you identify yourself kind of
ideologically or you know how do you
what do you call yourself
I'd say pragmatist technologist and I
for the most part try to decline any
kind of political or ideological label
outside of those for many reasons one is
that you know like I do believe in the
ability of technology to improve the
world and I would like to have large
possible coalition behind something like
that and I think that ideological in
political labels tend to repel more than
they tend to attract and you know
whereas a new technology
you don't need to be a Republican or
Democrat to you know buy cryptocurrency
or you know use ride-sharing or CNN
Airbnb and in fact many of the earliest
adopters our Democrats actually like you
know at least nominally so you know it
wouldn't be even if it's like arguably
like right no like anti regulation or
what have you
there was various moments in the 2016
campaign where Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton both from talked down
the sharing economy or the gig economy
but they almost exclusively took uber
where ride-sharing companies to campaign
events the ideal is to get something
which is so useful as a technology that
even people who might disagree with
certain aspects of it ideologically
nevertheless it improves their lives
right and so so at least the way I try
to identify is I'm a technologist who
wants to build things that improve
people's lives I think I was able to do
that with my first company hopefully we
can do that with you know this and other
ventures well who ya be do you have the
PhD and electrical excellence so who
were the egghead heroes of your life who
were the technologists that you look up
to straining vasa Ramanujan you know
India's greatest mathematician he's got
kind of a romantic story in India
because he's sort of the combination of
the the Einstein they're like you know
like smart guy but also a rags to quote
riches story even though he didn't get
rich he was truly destitute in India and
was able through pure genius to actually
become a mathematician at Cambridge and
and published a number of papers and he
died in a young way very romantically
and he's somebody who motivates me
because one of the things I'd like to do
at some point in the future is have like
a worldwide talent search for all these
kids around the world in South America
in Nigeria in the Middle East and
Eastern Europe and India and China who
for a reason you know between century
like missed out on them or missed out on
their parents and so now they could
actually with the internet have the
opportunity to rise so that's that's one
person I think about a lot second person
Lee Kuan Yew I'm so not necessarily a
scientist per se but yes was the father
of Singapore father Singapore that's
right um a pragmatist who you know if
you read his you know he's written a lot
he gave a bunch of interviews um you
know he had a great book third world
first and that's literally what he did
he took a country that was you know
really have no natural resources or any
advantages
it was a swampy kind of land it was a
post-colonial society it was
Riven by language at all these different
you know ethnic groups there that
weren't necessarily all that friendly he
turned it into you know one of the
wealthiest countries in the world and so
the choices he made there I think are
really interesting to look at because
Lee Kuan Yew you would not describe as
easily pigeon-holed as libertarian or
conservative or socialist or you know I
mean actually mixes from a lot because
it was definitely for economic freedom
also kind of authoritarian but also kind
of socialistic and yet the level of
government services that are provided by
that's right like Singapore's HSA is
simultaneously both to the right and to
the left of the United States so you
know they just say there the way it
works is you are forced to save in a
separate savings account which is to the
left of the US because it's not just a
tax like a forced savings account but
then you can spend in a completely free
market way from that forced savings
account so that's like to the right of
the American system because it's no
insurance or it doesn't work in the same
way so it's just something which is sort
of outside the bounds on and that's
something I think about a lot in the
context of startups for example because
you know startups have like a
combination of both right and left
aspects right classically right enough
aspects they have you know some degree
of hierarchy they have capitalism you
know they're funding and runway and
profit all those kinds of metrics
obviously which are typically right
right of central metrics but they work
in large part because they're
egalitarian they're mission-driven they
have informal attire they have a screw
the man attitude and the best ones
actually genuinely perpetuate or
accomplish a revolution right and that's
definitely not a right-of-center thing
that's not respect the existing
hierarchy it's how you think as you know
effectively you're living your entire
life in the 21st century or these cat I
mean we we need new categories mm-hmm
probably yeah I think so I'll give it an
example which is which i think is
interesting so you know when google
initially introduced free lunches um you
know like this is not like a long time
but like 15 years ago it was for many
you know what I call right-of-center CFO
type bean counters um this was looked at
as this really dumb you know liberal
hippie thing they were doing but it
actually turned out to be something that
was better by both metrics because it
gave both more commune
feeling within the organization
everybody had like something in common
they could all go to lunch right and it
was it was in a sense a seizure from
their paycheck right so you know rather
than giving everybody the right
libertarian thing would be given by an
extra thousand dollars and they'll beat
their utility will be increased that was
not what actually give him a dollar
hamburger and they love you like you're
the greatest thing in the world well I'm
not saying it might not even be it might
even be more expensive right so it
cheaper per se but it is something where
there was a solution that was not the
classically you know like dollars and
cents individual solution that did
optimist community feeling and so I
think a lot about stuff like that where
ultimately you're looking for a
pragmatic best outcome and not something
that just has to be right around as a
final question your father in India grew
up in a house or a hut with dirt floors
you grew up in Long Island which is you
know my old improved sure you're you
have a one-year-old child who now is
growing up and you know in the in the
Bay Area in San Francisco we have a very
successful set of parents um what are
the things that need to you know what
what kind of world do you think your
your son will grow up in and what what
is what are the one or two things that
will either make it much much better
than it is today already or will like
plunge us backwards in tough asking a
question I mean I think this
transitional era that we're going
through now I think is going to be
something where there's both nationalist
and socialist
responses to this kind of emerging cloud
economy that are often going to be you
know very negative and you know so one
thing I think a lot about you know when
my son actually is I probably want him
to go Satoshi and by that what I mean is
you know Satoshi Nakamoto is the world's
first pseudonymous billionaire but he
won't be the last right and when the
great things about Satoshi is you know
you couldn't discriminate against him
both positively or negatively right you
know if he's Bill Gates his son or you
know her daughter you wouldn't know that
but he will also go to know if he was
from some disfavored you know group or
whatever and in whatever country um he
just competes completely on the base of
ideas I want to start him at like kind
of that equality of opportunity level
then he knows whatever he achieved is
kind of on him in terms of the the kinds
things I would look out for I think it's
gonna be pretty good like the the
transitional kind of thing I actually
think that you know I believe in the
Steven Pinker thesis for the most part
that you know violence is decreasing
we're aware of it more because you know
there's the 24/7 news coverage but it is
something we're on net it's getting
better and especially if you know the
the long-term consequence of
cryptocurrency in the block students own
is to limit the ability of states to
wage wars maybe there's one big one
coming up that would be unfortunate
assuming he survives through that I
think it'll be pretty good
[Music]